hello everyone and welcome to another
spectacular game that happened in round
two of this year's data steel
Challengers Edition it is a game between
yerushpehach and Amin tabatabai and the
title pretty much sums it up one player
blunders a piece on move six and ends up
winning the game how is this possible
well as it turns out the resulting
positions uh after this blunder are so
complicated that uh well it seems that
even classical control is not enough
time to figure out uh everything that's
uh that's possible so let's dive
straight into it uh with the white
pieces opens with E4 and yes it features
the greatest opening of all times after
that one opening and that is the King's
Gambit E5 and pawn to F4 the king's
Gambit is on the board he captures an F4
accepting the Gambit and now Knight to
F3 and there are many ways to deal with
the uh Kings Gambit you could play D6
you could play D5 you could go for G5
still the most played move
um yeah you know it was played in the
olden days in matches between for
example morphine Anderson and still uh
to this day the the top move but here we
have Knight to F6 uh and now comes spawn
to E5 and okay still this is all very
well known Theory Knight to H5 uh now if
the Knight moves for example Queen H4
check can be very unpleasant so D for D6
and now comes Queen to E2 and here okay
you are threatening ecaptress and D6
with check you should really do
something about this and there are uh
various ways you could deal with this
you could just close the central with D5
uh you could also play D captures an E5
for example Knight captures an E5 and
queen to H for check now let's say King
to D1 this is very standard uh Kings
Gambit compensation if you want to call
it that Bishop to E7 Knight to F3 now
attacks the queen for example Queen goes
back and now Knights the C3 and it's not
easy black can't really Castle
um uh due to the bishop on E7 uh hanging
so you you still have to figure out how
to deal with this but it is very much
playable however in the game yeah I mean
played Bishop to E7 and there is a very
good reason why he played it uh even
though it's a move that should lose you
the game but I will not tell you why I
will just link an interview with uh I
mean that he gave after the game will be
the first link in the description below
so do check it out it's uh a very nice
interview uh so Bishop to E7 and this
just uh straight out wanders a piece now
the problem is look at this queen B5
check what's up with that and the Knight
on H5 is undefended so you just clear
the E file first e captures on D6 now
the bishop is hanging and also Queen B5
check will pick up the Knight so you
have to decide you want to lose the
Knight or do you want to lose the bishop
and here I mean as I understand it he
got off from the table he went to the
bathroom he was I imagine disgusted with
himself but he recollected himself came
back to the board and he said all right
I'm gonna make my opponent work for his
meal and he continued with Queen
captures and D6 giving up the Knight on
H5 so Queen B5 check Knight the C6 and
now Queen captures on H5 so what he has
for compensation is he will grab another
Pawn Knight captures on D4 and this is
where the position uh really becomes
interesting and uh if you're white here
you know that your opponent just
blundered you know that your opponent um
okay will play but uh chances are
you you are completely winning and of
course you know this uh the problem is
there's only one winning uh variation
for white here and it's not um it's not
that clear I will just show it to you so
here you have to play Knight captures on
D4 it's not a move you want to play you
want to continue development of course
that's kind of in the spirit of the
king's Gambit but your opponent just
blunder the piece uh you no longer care
about the spirit of the king's Gambit so
you have to capture on D4 and after
Queen captures now you're gonna play
Knight the C3 preparing Bishop to D3
after let's say black castles Bishop to
D3 G6 now you have to stop Checkmate uh
also the queen is attacked Queen back to
F3 now Bishop to H4 check of course you
will not allow uh White to hide the king
safety King to D1 now let's say C5
preparing C4 to win back material now
you're gonna play Knight E2 attack the
queen and once the queen moves somewhere
anywhere with the queen d8 you're still
threatening C4 You're Gonna Play Bishop
to D2 now c4 is not a problem you can
just capture that and after something
like Bishop to E6 you will play Knight
captures and F4 and slowly but surely
you will hide the king to the queen side
get this Rook into the game it will take
you uh several moves but you will
finally get to enjoy your extra piece
and have a completely winning position
without any positional issues so here
after Knight captures on D4 that was not
played in the game uh here uh here we've
played Bishop the D3 which is a nice
developing move of course he stops
castling as Checkmate is being
threatened but the problem is Pawn to G6
and now you have to move the queen away
from the defense of the Knight on F3 and
the Black Will Will just [ __ ] White's
King side so here Queen to A5 is played
Knight captures an F3 check G captures
and hear Black castles and okay now if
you look at this position white is still
up a piece but this uh definitely looks
like a position black might play even
voluntarily if if you know if you offer
it to someone I know a few players that
would very much love to play a position
like this so now white will have to
figure out a way how to get his King to
safety Knight to C3 okay you wanna
uh develop the bishop move the king
queen to E6 with check now we have
Knights the E2 and the bishop to H4 with
check King to D1 and now Queen the H3
attacking the pawn and F3 so Bishop
captures on F4 you wanna clear this path
for the white king queen captures an F3
and now King the D2 hoping to get your
Rook into the game and hide the king uh
all the way to the queen side but now
comes Bishop to H3 and again incredibly
complicated position now if you try Rook
8 to D1 which seems like it solves all
of your problems and the problem is the
rook fte8 and now you can't move the
king uh there are all sorts of problems
like Rook captures on E2 and then Queen
captures and F4 will just win black
material so we're gonna have to move the
bishop but now even ideas like Rook a to
d8 okay now you're gonna play Knight to
G4 because if you don't again you can
just play Rook captures on D3 and then
if you move the king Rook capture Sandy
3 and then pick up the Knight so here
you're gonna play Knight to G3 but now
Queen to F6 goes after the B2 pawn and
finally after King to C1 it seems like
white uh cleared everything white is now
saved there's G5 wins back material so
uh very very complicated so instead we
have Bishop to G3
uh getting that Bishop out of Harm's Way
and now Pawn to B6 uh is an incredible
move an incredible move by black because
it takes away the queen away from the
fifth Rank and uh that's a really
important thing to do you want to play
Bishop to G5 check and stop the white
king from escaping so Queen B5 but now
A6 we have Queen to C4 and finally
Bishop to G5 with check so Bishop to F4
and now Bishop to F6 putting pressure on
the B2 pawn and now Rook H to G1 and
here you could consider a lot of things
one thing you don't want to consider is
capturing B2 it seems like a great move
because then the white king will be in
the center of the board indefinitely the
problem is if you capture here then
comes Bishop captures on G6 and black
can just resign there's no good way to
handle this for example if captures a
rook captures you're gonna have to move
the king of course the F Pawn cannot
move uh King H7 uh sorry better King H7
Rook to H6 check and now once you go to
the G file The Rook comes to G1
let's say Bishop to G4 Rook to H4 and
here you resign there's nothing here I
mean if F5 just Queen captures on C7
everything is uh just falling apart here
Rook F7 Bishop E5 check King to G6 and
now you just Checkmate the black king
for example Queen to H6 with the
checkmate
so after this Rook H the G1 move uh Rook
F the E8 was played again with some very
nasty tricks here uh uh here best for
white would be to play Rook to G3 but
here uh Jurg rushed it a little bit his
position is still better slightly better
uh but he has to play Rook to G3 however
he rushed it with Rook 8 to E1 and now
uh and now it's Black's time to shine
and he does it again uh by playing Pawn
to B5 uh absolutely wonderful here uh
the problem is now how are you uh
defending the bishop on F4 yes the
Knight is defending it but broke
captures and E2 will remove the defender
of the bishop and then Queen captures an
F4 and there's a problem you can't
really do all that much of Queen before
just A5 this takes away the entire
fourth rank from the White Queen so
Queen captures and C7 this is the only
good way to continue but now Rook 8 to
C8 Queen to D6 still keeping an eye on
that Bishop but now uh here we have Rook
the E6 Bishop captures and B2 is also
fine uh you decide okay I'm not gonna
win back material I'm just gonna keep
the the king and D2 and uh chances are
you will very like to win this game but
he played Rook to E6 now what do you
play Rook the G3 very very important
move here if you go if you go Queen to
B4 there's a bishop p7 I mean disgusting
stuff here Queen to D4 now Rook to d8
and uh you are Never Getting Away From
Here whatever you play here I mean
there's just nothing here Bishop the B4
check is coming you're not gonna be able
to play C3 uh because then the the
bishop and D3 hangs there I mean the the
there's nothing here so instead after
rookie 6 Bishop to Rook to G3 only move
for white and now Queen to F2 and now
Bishop to E3 going after the queen if
you go for Rook captures on H3 there's
just Rook captures on D6 and after
Bishop captures Bishop captures on B2 so
okay you might argue that you have
compensation for the queen uh indeed you
have okay let's check Rook Rook Bishop
Bishop you will have a bishop Knight and
the Rook for the for the black queen
here but I mean your king is stuck on D2
with with no squares whatsoever a very
sad position for white so instead that's
why Bishop to E3 you cannot give up the
queen and now Queen captures on E1 this
is how the trade happens King captures
an E1 Rook captures on D6 Rook captures
on H3 and now Bishop captures on B2 and
if you count everything now you will see
that uh both players have a rook here
both players have a dark Square bishop
and white has a bishop and Knight for a
rook so okay uh if you count it that way
white is definitely better but black is
up to pawns so it's a very very tricky
so Rook to H4 uh preparing Ponte A4 to
eliminate these two queen side pawns but
now we have F5 Ponta A4 and now Bishop
to F6 here uh top of the buy starts
playing pretty much with engine level
Precision uh Bishop to F6 attacks The
Rook uh trying to get the Rook away from
the defense of the A4 Pawn Rook to B4
and now the tricky Bishop E7 spectacular
move to find now if you if you try
capturing just root captures on D3 and
the white resigns you will be down too
much material so you have to move the
Rook Rook to B1 and now look at this B
captures an A4 Rook to A1 and now A3
again with the same trick now if row
captures an A3 Rook E6 attacks the rook
and A3 and the bishop on E3 that's
undefended so here Bishop back to C1 and
now Rook the D5
uh preparing to put the Rook on the a
file uh because now Rook captures is
impossible to do Bishop captures and you
really should reconsider about this
bishop captures on A3 but I I think uh
jurgus was already pretty much uh
completely demoralized by by not uh uh
you know nurturing that Advantage from
move six all the way to a win uh that he
just went for Bishop captures and A3 but
now black is just uh straight up winning
so Rook to A5 attacks the bishop Bishop
to B2 Rook capture Sunny one Bishop
captures and now Pawn to A5 so now it's
a rook for for Bishop and Knight but uh
black with two extra pawns and with the
past a pawn will be incredibly difficult
to stop with Knight to F4 King to F7
starts bringing the king into the game
Knight to D5 and Bishop to D6 goes after
the H2 Pawn so H3 and The Rook to E8
with check King to D2 and now Bishop to
E5 he wants the tree create even more
material so it will be easier to push
his advantage to a win so Bishop
captures Rook captures and now Pawn the
C4 defending the Knight King the E6 and
here are pretty much anything you do
loses the game for black not pretty much
everything you do loses the game for
white but here after King to C3 there's
just a very very cool way to end the
game so feel free to pause the video and
try to find the winning idea for for
Tava to buy uh while I give you a couple
of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on uh spotting that
you don't need pieces to win this end
game and for those of you who just want
to enjoy the show it is a rook capture
Sunday 5. this is what I mean played uh
and it was in this position unmove 45
that year was better to resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here once you capture The Rook okay
white is up a full piece uh but uh
regardless of how you play this uh
there's just no way to hold uh to give
you an example let's say you've got
Bishop C2 you want to try to cover as
many squares here in front of the black
king also keep an eye on the A4 Square
black easily infiltrates the king's side
and now let's say King to D2 you're
gonna play King F4 uh now you lose the
H3 Pawn or you can try to defend it
let's say Bishop D3 King G3 and Bishop
to F1 but now A4 now the King has to go
stop the a pawn let's say King C3 You're
Gonna Play Pawn to F4 and after King to
B for now you just start advancing those
pawns and they will be to impossible to
stop for example G5 you're gonna start
bringing the king into the game King b3g
for captures captures the two connected
past pawns are stronger than anything uh
especially a bishop so King C4 let's say
King F2 and that's it Bishop D3 G3 and
you advance your Pawn to Victory so
absolutely spectacular game uh Rook
characters on D5 ends it uh truly
remarkable and uh yeah uh again not just
an absolutely spectacular game
absolutely spectacular uh by amine uh
for for not just resigning here or you
know starting to play whatever or just
going for a nonsense aggressive moves to
try and make something out of the
positions uh the rise uh he just played
good chess uh yeah gave him a few
chances he took them and in the end he
he wasn't just able to save the game he
was able to even win the game uh but
yeah I mean very very hard to even play
this with uh with white even after
winning the piece it was uh uh I mean
like I said only only one uh after
Knight captures Sunday for only one move
that allows white to keep the advantage
everything else just allows black to get
back into the game so not the the
greatest uh you know
ad for for King's Gambit as I know uh
you know a lot of you like myself are
big fans of the king's Gambit uh but you
know it's a great opening you can play
it you can win positions but you have to
be very very very precise it's a very
tactical opening and even even if you
win a piece on move six uh it will not
guarantee you a victory uh so yeah once
again huge congratulations to Amin for
winning a game being a full piece Down
In classical chess not something you see
very often I remember like a few years
ago Magnus Carlsen won against the Wayne
Jones uh also after blundering a piece
but you I mean you just don't see that
very often uh so yeah I hope you guys
enjoyed it play the Kings Gambit but
also know what uh what you are doing I
would like to thank doitran revision
reptiles YouTube safeshelter.org
hot water for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Tata
steel both Challenger and Masters
Edition until uh they finish so thank
you I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day